hello everyone my name is george
gonzalez
i work for agilent technologies and i'm
going to be reviewing
agilent's portfolio and some of the ways
we help our customers
here at agilent we strive to understand
your challenges
and with this knowledge deliver
solutions that will enable you to work
more productively
we do this by assembling a team of
knowledgeable people to understand your
needs
create that solution and deliver the
solution
we then stay engaged with you after you
purchase
our products our focus
our customers and our passion helping
customers solve
critical challenges in their
laboratories as they seek to improve the
world
the creation of hewlett packard back in
1939
was the early beginning of agilent in
1999
hewlett-packard recognized that the
company had become too diverse
and needed to focus on different
customers
they served this is when agilent
technologies was born
as an independent company once separated
from a
hewlett packard agilent quickly focused
on enabling customers to make
high quality measurements
to better serve the customers agilent
acquires a number of companies
to fill in products and technologies
that allow us to deliver
a more complete solution in 2012 agilent
acquired daco
to allow it to expand into clinical
measurements today agilent focuses on
seven
key markets pharmaceuticals
life sciences and research diagnostics
in clinical
food forensics environmental
and chemical and energy
agilent is a significant player in the
analytical
and diagnostic measurement business we
are a team of over
14 000 employees spread around the world
agilent is truly a global company that
delivers significant business
from three major geographies
this is reflected in our placement of
sales offices
logistics centers and business
facilities around the world
and enables us to ensure the delivery of
high quality solutions
to our customers
at agilent we understand that a solution
is more than an
innovative scientific a solution is when
measurement fits
your business model and enable you to
accomplish your objectives
that's reason why our business starts by
focusing on
customer needs it is our focus
on customers that is key to assembling
the right combination of instruments
consumables
software and services to deliver an
answer
you can trust
agilent has long been known for the
reliability and robustness of our
products
our instruments are designed and
manufactured to international quality
standards
we take product quality very seriously
and conduct a randomly chosen customer
satisfaction
survey periodically so that we can hear
from all customers how we are doing
and how they see us performing
the surveys are conducted by independent
third party
and are anonymous to make sure we get
our
unbiased thoughts
you consistently rank us at the top of
the industry for the reliability and
robustness
of our products and we thank you
agilent has a strong company culture
that starts with our senior management
and his practice throughout the company
we believe these values make agilent a
special place
to work and also a special company to
work with
you should expect agilent employees to
exhibit these values in your day-to-day
interactions with them
we're especially committed to our
uncompromising
integrity agilent has chosen to serve
seven key markets
agilent employees pay special attention
to understand
and develop workflow solutions that will
fit
the needs of the customer that work in
these markets
i happen to manage the chemical and
energy
segment
meeting the world's increasing need for
energy is a challenge
challenges include regulatory
requirements efficiency improvements
and good environmental stewardship
which impose impose tough demands on
your industry
agilent is committed to provide the
best-in-class instrumentation and
software
for the energy and chemical segment
agilent has been doing so for more than
50 years
agilent technologies provides custom or
standard
analyzer solutions configured for your
specific chemical analysis
we provide natural gas analyzers
refinery gas analyzers
and a variety of other standard test
method configurations
agilent has for more than 40 years
been collaborating with astm
international in the creation and
management of standardized
analysis procedures and many have been
developed
on agilent instruments including gc lc
ms ftar and gcms technologies
we also continue to monitor emerging
requirements
and trends in order to introduce new
test methods needed
by the industry through this partnership
as i mentioned earlier for more than 40
years agilent has collaborated with
organizations such as astm iso
san and others in the development of new
petroleum fuel lubricant
and other standards as such we are
uniquely positioned to design
comprehensive innovative solutions to
make your workflow
both productive and compliant
finally i'd like to thank you for your
time and listening
to this presentation and i hope you
enjoy this webinar series
if you have additional questions feel
free to reach out to your
account manager thank you and stay safe
you